the president's pick to run the CIA
spent more time talking about a
controversial program from the past than
her vision for the future during today's
confirmation hearing up on the hill
chief intelligence correspondent
Catherine Herridge was there and shows
us from Capitol Hill at her confirmation
hearing the first woman nominated to
leave the CIA said the controversial
post 9/11 interrogation program that
critics called torture is a thing of the
past my moral compass is strong I would
not allow the CIA to undertake activity
that I thought was immoral even if it
was technically legal Democrats
repeatedly pressed the CIA veteran who
spent 32 years undercover on her role in
the destruction of videotapes
documenting the waterboarding of at
least one al Qaeda operatives were you
an advocate for destroying the tape I
absolutely was an advocate if we could
within and conforming to US law and if
we could get policy concurrence to
eliminate the security risk posed to our
officers by those tapes Haspel said her
supervisor made the call
mr. Rodriguez who was the deputy
director for operations has made it
clear that he and he alone made the
decision to destroy the tapes
Hostel said multiple reviews found there
was no legal requirement to keep the
videos because the interrogations were
transcribed in CIA cables that are
official records some Democrats were not
satisfied do you think that a transcript
that says the detainee continued to
scream or the detainee appeared to be
drowning has the same gravity the same
reality as an actual video for three
years the videotape issue lingered
hospital said CIA officers were visible
and at risk the concern was an
irresponsible leak of our officers faces
to the world demonstrators interrupted
the public session a handful of times as
Democrats pressed for more information I
would really like to have on the record
whether you ever called for the program
to be continued which it sure sounds to
me like your answer suggested after 9/11
I didn't look too
go sit on the Swiss desk I stepped up I
was not on the sidelines I was on the
frontlines in the Cold War and I was on
the frontlines in the fight against Al
Qaeda President Obama's CIA director
John Brennan was a senior manager when
the interrogation program was
implemented and still got confirmed with
strong support from Democrats
by contrast Haspel was a more junior
employee with no policy authority you
and this president are being held to a
double standard if you had been
nominated by President Obama or if
Hillary Clinton had wanted nominate you
to be a CIT director how many votes do
you think he would have gotten today
Democratic Senator Joe Manchin confirmed
to Fox News that he will now vote for
Haspel Senate Majority Whip John Cornyn
believes other Democrats will follow and
Haspel will be easily confirmed
Republicans wanting to vote on the floor
the week of May 20th before the Memorial
Day recess
Brett Catherine Harridge live on the
hill Catherine thank you